so in this video you're going to see the
step following the listening well
reading section click here if you
haven't seen the video yet and you're
going to see how I'm going to use a
piece of paper and I'm going to read my
own music sheet that I have created in
there and I'm going to read it out loud
at a specific rhythm so without further
ado let's get started
ghosts and goblins October 31st is a
night for fun and fright children of all
ages dress up in costumes there are
little girls who dress up as fairies
princesses ballerinas and the like there
are little boys who dress up as
firefighters policemen and superheroes
you also have the children who dress up
as furry animals or ghoulish ghosts one
thing is certain no matter what costume
you choose there is sure to be a lot of
candy and chocolate involved on
Halloween I can remember going
trick-or-treating as a child and using a
pillowcase as a goody bag this ensured
that I would have plenty of room for the
ridiculous amounts of chocolate that I
collected remember having many
stomachaches in the week that followed
Halloween I probably had enough candy to
last a month but I ate it all within a
few days some parents take their
children's candy and will only allow
them a certain amount each day however
my mom wanted to get it over with she
thought it was better to let me eat it
all at once than to have to listen to me
line about candy for a whole month you
might have the impression that Halloween
is just for kids but you would be wrong
many adults take part in the festivities
as well for example there are many
parties that take place all over the
city
most people dress up in costumes and
often there are prizes given for the
best ones some adults spend months and a
lot of money coming up with unique and
elaborate costumes I believe that some
adults have more fun on Halloween than
most children do furthermore many adults
and teenagers like to set up fireworks
and firecrackers there are often
wonderful firework displays at parks and
schools usually they are put on on by
firefighters to make sure that nobody
gets hurt October 31st is generally not
a peaceful night so if you think you
will be going to bed early you had
better think again often there are
teenagers setting off firecrackers until
all hours in the morning so here you
have it this is a simple technique where
you're going to read the text that you
yourself have marked phonetically at a
rhythm which allows you to tackle both
pronunciation articulation of the sounds
and also to pronounce things and
uttering things with the right
intonation that is really important
because what normally happens is that
people either care about pronunciation
too much missing the forest for the
trees or they focus on intonation but
they mispronounce the words and this is
a balance between the two things it's
really effective it's really simple and
it can work
wonders for your pronunciation
[Music]